hey what's up I'm Justine and welcome to
ask IJ this is the show where you guys
ask me questions and I answer them
[Music]
hey you can ask
hey hey you can ask I choose let's get
to it
epic question Taylor also know if I'm a
mermaid or a pirate and you know what
I've actually been both of those things
I don't know which Club to use I don't
know the big one well help you dear i J
Wii U or PS Vita now these are two
different consoles the Wii U is
something that I've gotta be sitting at
home and playing and the PS Vita is
something that I'll be taking outside
and taking with me on the go to really
compare those to the honey budget cares
how do I feel
don't care coca-cola or Pepsi both Danny
wants to know if I could grow a mustache
would I let it grow out and yes I would
what's the most fun thing that I did the
e3 actually just being at e3 was really
fun but lemme tell you what the most
embarrassing thing was me and my sister
dance to dance central to and we did
terrible
[Music]
have I ever lost my iphone and couldn't
find it there have been some times where
I've lost my iPhone but most recently I
dropped my iPhone in the shower now I
know what you're thinking just seeing
why are you showering with your iPhone
well actually wasn't showering with my
iPhone I had it sitting up on a ledge
and I was listening to some fat beats
while I showered and what do you know it
fell into the tub and I didn't actually
know that had fallen into the tub I just
thought if I can't feel it when I look
down there's no vial of shampoo that's
gonna feed me I'm gonna go that way I go
in a tub of white so my poor little wife
and juice out there getting drenched do
I know any Spanish songs uh no I don't
but if it's any consolation I do have
Caliente a Spanish Sirius satellite
radio station programmed in the car
what's my favorite dance this one I swim
sorta see the problem is can't swim very
well
[Music]
what's my favorite Gaga's song I think
right now it's probably the the one that
goes like what she'll me UT so breezy
she'll breathe so great and now it's
time for Justine please put me in your
ask IJ episode and if you're wondering
how you get your comment here all you
have to do is leave a comment below here
on YouTube saying please put me in your
ask IJ episode and then I put you here
okay
yeah daily good question my dream job in
high school was actually to be a
computer programmer I took a bunch of
courses we took basic C++ and Java that
I realized that I actually liked
designing the interfaces to these
programs more than actually doing the
coding itself so I decided to go to
school for multimedia and graphic design
and here we are today look what I'm
doing look what I'm doing what am i
doing making youtube videos my favorite
Disney character is I don't know Little
Mermaid can I make this face you're not
even making a face how boring but yeah I
can le french geek wants to know if I
love coffee bean and actually absolutely
love coffee bean and I used to drink the
coffee every single day but then I
realized I was wasting a lot of money on
just stupid coffee and I should probably
save my money so I can buy more type of
products Phil bur Mack is asking if I
like the sub that you made for me and
actually absolutely do love it thank you
for writing my name on it
and my favorite fast-food restaurant now
that you mentioned I actually really
like Subway and Wendy's I can love
Wendy's rows I want to know what color
my socks are let me show you
ah tie-dye crazy Chris Cole wants to
know if I'm looking forward to modern
warfare 3 and let me tell you what yes I
am I got to see some demos of it at e3
and let me tell you what I'm excited
don't know what this is don't know what
that is stop it I can't stop I can't
stop I can't stop my favorite thing to
do in the summer is go to the beach I
always go on vacation with my family I
guess who's a little sassy - baby I'm
fighting it on my knees that's me oh hey
way from here you're killing me Hey Oh
me me you're gonna see all of the vlogs
that I post on my other channel if I had
a turtle look what I named it I wouldn't
even Billie was my favorite place to
plank well I don't know I plant in a lot
of places Twitter question well I think
of Nicki Minaj I think she's a little
crazy but I like her
well you've got my heartbeat runnin away
well minimum of a - face my biggest fear
is probably getting my teeth knocked out
it's kind of a really scary thing for me
and also spiders and bugs yeah what I
pull if he wants an if I Drive as bad in
real life as I do in la Noir and maybe
not that bad no I just got it I just
stole what I mean oh my god what is this
look look out oh no
hey move it why would you just put a
freaking oh gosh Gracie is saying Sally
sold seashells by the seashore what did
Suzy sell no Suzy salad snacks Super
Bass was high school like for me I don't
know I'm just glad it's over
for those of you that are still in high
school let me tell you what yeah I know
I feel yeah this is a pretty good
question um Tanana moon high hands is
saying Collette wipe shake our recently
planked on Shea's head what are your
thoughts on that how will you respond
well I'll respond with this plank
[Music]
Danah would you go on a date with
gurning Tohono no 15 I don't know she
said maybe if you got in here so yeah
thank you guys so much for watching this
episode of ask I J don't forget there's
a part two where I answer the questions
that you guys asked me on my website and
those can be viewed at iJustine cone and
of course don't forget to subscribe so
you'll know what I launch new videos
here on YouTube and check out the rest
of my YouTube channels right there and
yeah check it out I'll see you guys soon
bye